-Performing her solo debut
single "Have Mercy,"
give it up for Chlöe!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Good evening, everyone.
Thank you for coming out.
I would like to perform the big
booty sonata in C sharp minor.
Thank you.
♪♪
♪ Boy, you looking at me like
I ain't give you no choice ♪
♪ If I count to three,
bet you be on your knees ♪
♪ Wrapped 'round my hand
like a Cartier ♪
♪ You can't get this thickness
out of your mind ♪
♪ He say he like
that Laffy Taffy ♪
♪ He so goofy, call me daddy ♪
♪ Go stupid, he go daffy ♪
♪ Introduce me to his ♪
♪ He can never live without me ♪
♪ I'm so real,
I'm never capping ♪
♪ Got it like that, like that ♪
♪ I can take it, take it there ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ 'Cause my booty so big ♪
♪ Lord, have mercy ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ Have mercy ♪
♪ Chloe on the beat ♪
♪ Teach you about the thing ♪
♪ Big, fat ass ♪
♪ Big, fat ass, ass ♪
♪ Big, fat ass, ass, ass ♪
♪ Big, fat ass ♪
♪ Big, fat ass, ass ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ Work, work it, work it,
work, work it ♪
♪ Work it, work-work,
work it, work it ♪
♪ Teach you a couple things ♪
♪ Work, work it, work it,
work-work, work it, work it ♪
♪ Chloe on the beat ♪
♪ Teach you couple things ♪
♪ Booty so big, booty so big ♪
♪ Booty so big ♪
♪ I can teach you
a couple things ♪
♪ Boy, you looking at me like
I ain't give you no choice ♪
♪ If I count to three,
bet you be on your knees ♪
♪ You wrapped 'round my hand
like a Cartier ♪
♪ You can't get this thickness
out of your mind ♪
♪ He say he like
that Laffy Taffy ♪
♪ He so goofy, call me daddy ♪
♪ Go stupid, he go daffy ♪
♪ Introduce me to his ♪
♪ He can never live without me ♪
♪ I'm so real, I'm never ♪
♪ If he got it like that,
like that ♪
♪ I can take it, take it there ♪
♪ 'Cause my booty so big, work ♪
♪ Lord, have mercy ♪
♪ Keep bossing like I do? ♪
♪ I keep flossing like I do ♪
♪ I keep saucing like I ♪
♪ Why keep costing like it do? ♪
♪ My jeans between ♪
♪ Get a piece of me ♪
♪ I can teach you
a couple things ♪
♪ How to serve a man,
how to work a man ♪
♪ It's on purpose I'm doing it ♪
♪ Big body language
like speaking Spanglish ♪
♪ I'll educate ya
how to do this [bleep] ♪
♪ Temporary,
that's never rare-y ♪
♪ I'm necessary ♪
♪ Yeah, I am that ♪
♪ You can't get this thickness
out of your mind ♪
♪ So big ♪
♪ Lord, have mercy ♪
♪ Booty so big, work ♪
♪ So big ♪
♪ How do, how do ♪
♪ Boss it like I do ♪
♪ Get up in between my ♪
♪ Teach you a couple ♪
♪ Work it ♪
♪♪
♪ In my jeans, you can't get up
in between, babe ♪
♪ I can teach you
a couple things ♪
♪ You better [bleep]
pay attention ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]